[Musique]
c'est pas forcément une très bonne
nouvelle pour l'économie mondiale de
voir un prix du pétrole qui s'effondre
aussi rapidement autour de 30 dollars le
baril parce que ça montre une chose
c'est qu'il ya pas assez de coordination
entre les grandes économies de la
planète
[Musique]
l'effondrement du baril de pétrole qui
est vraiment spectaculaire on assiste à
une chute de quelque 30% du baril dans
la journée ce lundi matin donc sans
précédent pourquoi bien tout simplement
parce que la demande de pétrole d'abord
en chine était en train de s'effondrer
l'économie chinoise est totalement
paralysée et la chine c'est 13 % de la
demande mondiale de pétrole
l'épidémie s'étendant au reste du monde
les pays producteurs redoutaient une
baisse accrue de la demande et les prix
étaient en train de chuter
spectaculairement
c'est pourquoi jeudi et vendredi dernier
les pays de l'opep menée par l'arabie
saoudite et leurs alliés la russie se
sont rencontrés à vienne siège de l'opep
pour essayer de trouver une parade pour
essayer de soutenir les cours du pétrole
bien viennent ça a été l'échec
l'arabie saoudite et son allié russe ne
sont pas parvenus à s'entendre pour
baisser la production afin de soutenir
le cours est alors la grande surprise ce
lundi matin c'est que l'arabie a décidé
non pas de fermer les vannes pour
essayer de soutenir les cours mais au
contraire de les ouvrir de brader
littéralement son pétrole à ses clients
en asie en amérique et en europe
ceci afin de préserver sa part de marché
on se retrouvera en fait à une course à
une rivalité entre l'arabie la russie
les autres pays producteurs
chacun voulant préserver sa part du
gâteau alors que le gâteau est en train
de rétrécir de west rock en seine saint
denis
en fait depuis trois ans l'opep et la
russie la russie qui est le deuxième
producteur mondial de brut derrière les
etats-unis l'arabie qui est le troisième
producteur et premier exportateur
ces deux géants se sont entendus pour
essayer de maintenir les cours sans
toujours grand succès mais il était
parvenu à s'entendre à plusieurs
reprises pour réduire un peu la
production ce qui avait permis quand
même de soutenir les cours
mais dans une situation de crise chacun
défend son propre intérêt c'est ce qui
est en train de se produire ce lundi
matin et ce qui va se produire dans les
jours à venir
le problème c'est que l'arabie saoudite
est en position beaucoup plus fragile
que la russie la russie actuellement à
des réserves financières plus
importantes que l'arabie l'arabie pour
maintenir son budget à flot a besoin
d'un baril beaucoup plus élevé que la
russie donc actuellement c'est vraiment
chacun pour sa peau chacun attend de
voir qui fera un geste dans l'autre sens
chacun pour soi dans un contexte où
clairement le marché est défavorable aux
producteurs défavorable parce que ces
derniers mois l'offre était extrêmement
abondante notamment grâce à la
production spectaculaire des pétroles de
schiste aux états unis et face à cette
offre
on avait une demande dont la croissance
ralentissait il faut bien avoir à
l'esprit que la croissance continuer
d'augmenter ces derniers mois mais à un
moindre rythme est là le retournement
spectaculaire c'est que ce lundi matin
l'agencé internationale pour l'énergie
annonce que pour la première fois depuis
2009 la demande mondiale de pétrole va
bien diminué à cause du coronavirus une
première diminution depuis 2009 donc
extrêmement défavorable aux pays
producteurs